When Caliban first steps onto the screen in
Logan, it's impossible to tell who's under
that killer costume.
But after he took off his bandana and goggles,
a little bell of recognition probably went
off in your head — there's something familiar
about the photosensitive mutant tracker.
Caliban is played by British writer, comedian,
and actor Stephen Merchant.
But he's had quite a career long before he
landed the choice role of Charles Xavier's
caretaker.
So where on Earth have we seen this guy before?
Merchant began his career doing stand-up and
sketch comedy before meeting Ricky Gervais
in 1997, when Gervais gave him a job at London's
X-F-M radio station.
The duo hosted a cult weekend radio show for
several years, introducing the world to their
future podcast co-host Karl Pilkington …
“You do realize…”
"Sorry, I've gotta stop you, mate, cuz the
little earpiece has come off in his ear!"
… and later teamed up as co-creators of
one of the most critically acclaimed comedies
of all time: The Office.
In addition to creating the comedy classic,
Merchant also had a small appearance in series
two, showing up as one of Gareth's friends,
nicknamed the "Ogg Monster" …
"Don't have a go at the eyes, because that
is astigmatism that I've had from the age
of five, so that's what makes them a bit bulbous."
Merchant and Gervais both served as executive
producers on the American version of the show.
and wrote the episode "The Convict," which
means Merchant helped give the world "Prison
Mike"...
"What was the food like in prison?"
"Gruel… sandwiches.
Gruel omelettes.
Nothin’ but gruel."
… and for that, the world is eternally grateful.
In 2005, Merchant and Gervais followed-up
The Office with another acclaimed cringe comedy,
Extras.
The series follows Gervais as a desperate
background actor trying to break into the
spotlight.
Merchant plays his incompetent agent ...
"It took me two days to realize they're eight
hours ahead."
"They're behind."
"Are they?"
"Yes."
"That explains quite a lot."
Merchant's performance scored him a best actor
prize at the British Comedy Awards.
That same year, Merchant and Gervais launched
the popular Ricky Gervais Show podcast, which
was later reimagined as a cartoon for HBO
…
"Even cavemen had little pants on.
Why haven't they—"
"Whoa!"
"Slow down."
"Rewind."
In 2011, the two reunited for Life's Too Short,
a series based around the fictionalized life
of Warwick Davis, the actor who played Wicket
the Ewok in Return of the Jedi.
And in 2010, Merchant and Gervais produced
and appeared in An Idiot Abroad, a documentary
series featuring Karl Pilkington being sent
to exotic locations …often against his will.
In 2007, Merchant made his big screen debut
in Edgar Wright's Hot Fuzz alongside Simon
Pegg…and appeared very briefly again that
same year with Pegg in Run Fatboy Run.
In 2009, Merchant had a quick cameo in the
Ricky Gervais-helmed The Invention of Lying,
but his profile got much higher the following
year, when Merchant showed up alongside Dwayne
Johnson in Disney's Tooth Fairy, playing The
Rock's otherworldly case worker.
Since then, Merchant appeared briefly in Cemetery
Junction, which he also wrote and directed
with Gervais, played third fiddle to Jason
Sudeikis and Owen Wilson in the Farrelly brothers
flop Hall Pass, and shared the screen with
Halle Berry in the dreadful Movie 43, among
a smattering of other small roles.
And of course, if you didn't catch any of
those movies, you may have run across Merchant
while holding a controller.
Video game fans could never forget his role
as the sweet-then-sadistic Wheatley from Portal
2:
"I honestly do wish I could take it all back,
and not just cuz I’m stranded in space.
I know who you are, mate!"
Merchant finally struck out on his own in
2013 with HBO's Hello Ladies.
The short-lived series followed the character
of Stuart Prichard, an Englishman who's moved
to Los Angeles in the hopes of becoming a
big-time ladies man.
Of course, Stuart isn't as debonair as he
thinks.
Instead, he's the kind of socially awkward
jerk who lies about a handicapped friend being
a war vet so he can worm his way inside a
swanky club.
Merchant filled the show with moments from
his actual love life, using his "most pitiful
dating stories" to create some truly awkward
scenes …
"Wade, as in Roe v. Wade.
It was a famous case about a woman's right—
"
"They know what it is.
No need to bring up abortion — til we need
to."
Hello Ladies only lasted one season before
HBO pulled the plug, although Merchant was
able to give viewers closure with a story-ending
movie.
Merchant has appeared on Comedy Central's
Drunk History three times, always playing
an American president.
He's donned a top hat twice to play Abraham
Lincoln, as well as sporting a wig for the
part of George Washington.
"The guy doesn't even speak English, so he's
says blah blah blah blah blah blah blah."
It only makes sense that Merchant has played
two of America's taller presidents.
But even though Washington stood at 6'2" and
Lincoln measured up at 6'4", the 6-foot-7-inch
Englishman still has them beat.
In 2015, Merchant helped create the show Lip
Sync Battle.
It all started in 2013, when Merchant was
talking with The Office's John Krasinski about
what Krasinski should do for his upcoming
appearance on Late Night with Jimmy Fallon,
and they decided on a lip syncing contest.
Fallon reused the skit multiple times, with
Merchant once coming aboard to face off against
Fallon and Joseph Gordon-Levitt.
Soon, the concept made its way over to Spike,
where it became Lip Sync Battle.
The lanky Merchant even once donned a crop
top and pair of chaps for his take on Christina
Aguilera's "Dirty" …
“That’s when we take it to the parking
lot, and I bet you somebody’s gonna call
the cops.
Uh-oh, here we go.”
If you still don't recognize Merchant, maybe
his appearance on the most popular sitcom
in America will jog your memory?
In 2015, he appeared as math teacher Dave
Gibbs on the CBS smash Big Bang Theory, dating
Amy following her break-up with Sheldon.
Dave turns out to be a Sheldon superfan, asking
fanboy questions about his favorite theoretical
physicist rather than actually having a real
conversation with his date.
But all's well that ends well, since Dave
helps Sheldon and Amy get back together, encouraging
the socially awkward scientist to patch things
up …
"Kiss her, you brilliant fool!”
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!